[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle saison n'a
d'information locale sur tv et soixante
dix huit voici les titres de ce lundi de
septembre jour de rentrée pour plus de
trois cent cinq mille élèves dans les
yvelines ils ont repris ce matin le
chemin de l'école du collège ou du lycée
jour de première aussi pour le nouveau
directeur académique antoine destrés qui
a pris ses fonctions cet été il est
notre invité une rentrée et des
nouveautés avec principalement la
réforme du lycée et du baccalauréat qui
entre dans le concret mais aussi
l'instruction obligatoire dès trois ans
est la suite du dédoublement des classes
également le point dans cette édition
et puis on vous parle du rer v réseau
express régional vélo ce projet porté
par le collectif d'associations un
collectif d'associations l'objectif
c'est de relier l ensemble des pistes
cyclables existantes pour en faire un
réseau cohérent
en ile-de-france le porte parole du
collectif vélos ile de france sera en
plateau à la fin de ce journal et on
commence tout de suite bien sûr par l
information du jour avec la rentrée des
classes pour à plus de trois cent cinq
mille jeunes d yves hinse était
également votre rentrée avoue antoine
destrés bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau vous êtes le
directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale des yvelines vous
avez été nommé cet été en remplacement
de serge clément qui est visé par une
enquête pour harcèlement et qui a été
démis de ses fonctions est ce que cette
rentrée a pu se préparer sereinement
est-ce que voilà vous étiez prêts pour
cette rentrée dans les yvelines
oui nous nous étions prêts gt gt en
poste en effet autour du 15 de 15
juillet officiellement nommé le 22
juillet j'ai pu faire le tour des
services voir si effectivement pour les
écoles pour les collèges pour lycées
tout était bien prêt salles l'été
je vous confirme et aujourd'hui que
c'est l'été puisque la rentrée s'est
bien passée dans dans nos établissements
et nos écoles des yvelines aura
l'occasion de dresser un premier bilan
dans un instant la rentrée c'est bien
sûr un grand moment pour les élèves et
leurs parents c'est une source de stress
pour certains à réjouissance pour
d'autres ce matin ce matin nous étions à
l'école élémentaire vigée lebrun à bois
d'arcy la fin des vacances a sonné
aurélia huit ans rentre en ce2 à l'école
élémentaire vigée-lebrun de bois d'arcy
son père accompagne sa petite dernière
pour sa reprise
j'ai pris quelques heures pour
les rennais pour amener ma fille à
l'école un retour à l'école amorcée
pendant les vacances
m comme aurélia 252 élèves font leur
rentrée à l'école élémentaire
vigée-lebrun de bois d'arcy pour
certains parents c'est une journée
marquante avec l'entrée au cp de leurs
enfants
on a pris un toujours la première
journée si ça va bien se passer
c'est alors à ses repères bon voilà
c'est un peu stressant
les élèves eux sont inquiets de la
composition de leur classe tous au
regard de la liste avec attention s'il
est content d'être avec tous ses
camarades tant mieux quoi c'est parti
pour une bonne rentrée dernier bisou aux
parents la première journée d'école de
l'année débute en musique on a choisi
des deschamps relativement facile avec
des refrains qui sont faciles à
mémoriser donc les élèves nouveaux vont
pouvoir s'intégrer tout de suite au
groupe de l'école une reprise également
pour les enseignants de cette école
élémentaire
c'est la quatorzième rentrée pour cette
maîtresse il faudra les mettre en
confiance ils m'ont la plupart me
connaissent déjà mais va s'assurer de
stars et on va ensuite bien sûr instauré
les principales règles de vie pour tout
se déroule bien pour l aller chez
prochaines vacances le 16 octobre au
soir avec avant la traditionnelle photo
de classe un reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et de manon varaldo est
passé le stress ou l'excitation de cette
rentrée comment s'est déroulée cette
première matinée de classe patrick
jacques de dixmude et margot du roi
elles sont allés poser la question
devant l'école élémentaire francis
poulenc à guillon
[Musique]
et on a
passée la page de garde des cahiers on
peut manquer de revoir les copains la
maîtresse wayne revient t'amuser tu
penses à ta mais oui ça est une poésie
ce matin et j'ai écrit je fais des
matches s'achemine et j'ai et je vais
voir ma nous
et en cp à ça va changer la petite
section tu es content tu deviens un
grand on a fait les fournitures
on a rencontré tous qu'est ce qui t'as
plus le plus plus de ta rentrée
[Musique]
j'aimais quand hergé nos amis seront en
plateau avec moi antoine destrés
directeur académique des yvelines quel
bilan vous faites sur cette première
journée de rentrée dans le département
vous parliez tout à l'heure dans un
bilan plutôt positif
oui la rentrée s'est bien passée une
rentrée sereine comme c'est beau un
directeur accalmie qui a toujours un
sujet un les ouvertures fermetures de
classes en école maternelle et une école
aisément sa partie des dossiers chauds
de la rentrée si oui mais finalement ça
s'est bien passé on avait souhaité qu'on
anticipe la plupart des mesures
donc le bilan ce soit c'est qu'on a fait
cette fermeture des endroits où les
effectifs avaient baissé pendant les
vacances et puis 19 ouvertures mais en
réalité les sur l'ensemble de ces
mesures seules 300 nouvelles aujourd'hui
les autres avaient été anticipés
anticipé vendredi et pourquoi parce que
dans votre portail s'est dit voilà quand
on rentre en cp ou dans une autre classe
mais un cp tout particulièrement de
savoir qui va être le maître qui va être
avait pressé c'est essentiel donc c'est
une chose à laquelle je tiens c'est à
dire que les mesures des décisions
d'ouverture de fermeture soient prises
en amont de la rentrée on a presque un
sans faute
c'est bon on essaiera le sans-faute
prochaine avec tout j'en voulais dire
des réajustements de cette carte
scolaire on précise des mobilisations
qui ont lieu une lieu ce matin à
vernouillet ou encore
villennes-sur-seine y ait mobilisation
également en vue antoine destrés ce
mercredi à rambouillet elle est
professeur du collège rond du rondeau
ont prévu de faire grève
il a protestent contre la suppression
d'un poste de cpe et la diminution du
poste de présence du temps de présence
pardon de l'infirmière est ce que c'est
une situation qui est prise en compte
par vos services est ce qu'il ya des
discussions en cours sur ce sujet alors
juste une petite correction vers ailier
en fait c'était un contact avec le maire
ce week-end donc tout allait bien ce
matin puisque j'ai réimplanter le s'est
permis l'affectation d'une personne
finalement ça s'est réglé avait envoyé
et à villennes sur seine tout était
réglé
à midi donc voilà ça faisait partie des
trois situations villennes sur seine
dont je parlais et sur ses réalisations
vue à rambouillet donc on en a parlé
avec mon équipe et donc on va rencontrer
on va rencontrer l'équipe et surtout des
représentants des parents d'élèves
demain demain mardi
faut qu'on comprenne ou et le le
malentendu la difficulté on doit pouvoir
sortir de ce problème
rentrée des élèves rentrée aussi pour
plus de 19000 enseignants avec des
petits nouveaux ils sont trois cent
soixante et un professeur des écoles
stagiaire à faire leurs premiers pas
dans les yvelines vous les avez
accueilli antoine destrés en compagnie
de la rectrice charline avenay le
mercredi dernier c'était à l'université
versailles saint quentin des professeurs
débutants forcément stressé en vue de la
rentrée d'autant que certains elles ne
sont pas de la région parisienne et
doivent par exemple trouver un logement
écouter deux d'entre eux on est
plusieurs à être dans cette situation là
et par rapport aux partenaires c'est
vrai que
ça nous apporte enfin des réponses aux
questions qu'on est amené à se poser à
et sans chercher nous-mêmes à droite à
gauche beaucoup de stress parce que on
débute tout juste donc et ça va être une
année très chargée pour nous avec
énormément de travail personnel donc il
va falloir que qu'on gère l'aspect fac
et l'aspect aussi à l'école comme une
journée d'accueil qui est un classique à
chaque rentrée dans les yvelines y est
important pour le service d'accueillir
ces nouveaux professeurs pour les
rassurer sur certaines thématiques les
informer aussi oui les informait les
rassurer et puis surtout les accompagner
tout au long de l'année donc on l'aura
expliquer un peu comment ça coup cet
accompagnement se ferait d'un côté de
lynn spence l'institut de formation et
puis évidemment sur sur le terrain
puisqu'ils partagent leur temps entre
moitié sur le terrain moitié moitié à
l'école oui donc et on les accompagne
il ya vraiment j'ai découvert un
accompagnement de qualité de la part des
deux tous les formateurs pour que le but
c'est qu'ils soient tous titulaires
étaient à la fin d'année sur toutes les
élèves apprennent tous dans de bonnes
conditions
une rentrée vous savez antoine des
strikes son lot de nouveautés pour faire
le point mais quel ennemi drogon soir
bonsoir c'est la rédaction ahora
également aujourd'hui tv 78 c'est notre
entrée à tout le monde beaucoup
nouveautés michael en cette rentrée
notamment en maternelle
alors c'est l'une des grosses nouveautés
de cette rentrée en france et donc dans
l'académie de versailles l'âge de
l'instruction obligatoire passe de six à
trois ans cette mesure va avoir peu
d'impact près de 97% des enfants étaient
déjà scolarisés dès cet âge l'année
dernière dans l'académie versaillaise on
va même un peu plus loin un plan en
maternelle a été créée depuis plusieurs
années pour accueillir les enfants de
moins de 3 ans cette année ils seront
3829 élèves 18 % de plus par rapport à
2016 on écoute la rectrice chanel à
venelles au micro de tv 78 elles
touchent pas un nombre très important
d'élèves mais enfin tout de même elle
permet à ceux qui en est éloigné
d'accéder à l'école et puis surtout elle
s'accompagne d'une réflexion sur l'école
maternelle qui doit amener
acquérir plus tôt les fondamentaux par
exemple comment on appréhende les
nombres les lettres dès la maternelle
et voilà c'est tout ce que charrie cette
réforme de l'instruction obligatoire à 3
ans un autre axe fort pour cette rentrée
l'écologie ce n'est pas forcément une
nouveauté mais les gestes écologiques
vont être intensifiées dans les lieux
d'éducation cette année deux cent
soixante treize établissements de
l'académie sont labellisés développement
durable ils luttent généralement contre
le gaspillage alimentaire mais également
en proposant des actions pour protéger
la planète
dès cette rentrée 2010 9 c'est nouveau
des élèves éco délégués sont représentés
dans des conseils de vie collégiennes et
lycéennes
objectif favoriser l'engagement des
élèves et leur initiative pour une
gestion durable de l'établissement on
écoute la rectrice charline avenel
l'environnement le développement durable
est vraiment devenu un sujet phare
pourquoi parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que l'ondé de choc avec nos élèves est
colossal des élèves qui trie à l'école
ça veut dire des élèves qui trie dans
leur famille des familles qui change de
pratiques et on forme
on referme une jeunesse avec une onde de
choc pour les générations futures
les terminaux au lycée michael avec de
gros changements qui sont à prévoir pour
les lycéens avec cette réforme du
baccalauréat
on en parle beaucoup un grégory c'est le
gros dossier de cette rentrée exit les
premières s es et l place un parcours
beaucoup plus personnalisé qui sera mise
en place dès cette année pour les élèves
de 1re cette spécialité ou plus seront
proposés dans la quasi-totalité des
lycées du territoire en parallèle le
système d'évaluation va également
changer les élèves de 1re passeront dès
le deuxième trimestre une série
d'épreuves sur table ils ont également
un examen au troisième trimestre des
partiels lycéens qui compteront pour 30
% de la note finale du contrôle continu
à réaction c'est évidemment une très
bonne chose parce que ça évite le stress
de l'examen ça permet d'échelonner ça
permet d'avoir une progressivité et puis
ça permet à l'ensemble du système de ne
pas être dépendant de ces quelques jours
de la fin juin donc voilà c'est une
modalité beaucoup plus facile est
vraiment dans l'intérêt des élèves
merci à mikel pour cette chronique sur
les nouveautés justement l'une des
nouveautés
antoine destrés michael a terminé par
sas et sur la réforme des lycées la
réforme du baccalauréat qui rentre dans
le concret comment ça se met en place
dans les yvelines est ce que tous les
lycées sont prêts pour cette réforme
écoutez je vais vous donner une
information qui prouve que en effet les
choses se passent bien
on a nous avons contacté les proviseurs
de tous les lycées pour savoir si le
point qui était le plus sensible à ce
stade c'est à dire des emplois du temps
des élèves
on va parler d'eux on a plus
effectivement s mais des spécialités
donc des combinaisons beaucoup plus
complexe et donc est ce que les emplois
du temps était prêt et donc tous les
lycées nous ont répondu vendredi va même
plus c'était plusieurs jours que voilà
les choses se passaient bien
donc quand même témoin de salue au
passage la mobilisation de qualité des
chefs d'établissement qui soucie de leur
équipe pour réussir cette réforme
intervient enfin une autre nouveauté on
précise juste que le déploiement du à
dédoublement des classes se poursuit ça
sur la zone des yvelines a été mis en
place depuis deux ans vous vouliez
placer l'action aussi sur le handicap
avec la mise en place
d'un service départemental de l'école
inclusive qui est en place voilà à
partir de cette année oui alors juste
peut être quelques chez wimille élèves
en situation de handicap dans dans les
écoles établissements des yvelines peu
près 5000 qui ont un accompagnant et
puis à peu près 2000 accompagnant pour
ces élèves dont koussa dit les choses de
manière importante piste ne serait ce
que les élèves en situation de handicap
vous en avez à peu près trois fois plus
qu il y a qu il y à 13 ans donc on voit
bien
pour autant ce qui est ce que le
ministre a décidé c'est qu'en effet on
accentuerait l'action en direction de
des parents d'une part nous accompagnent
et mieux encadrer mieux accueilli donc
les parents à un numéro je ne sais pas
si j'ai le temps de donner donner 2 01
39 23 62 63 un parent qui a une question
à poser sur son dos et sur le dispositif
il la pause on a dans les vingt quatre
heures il doit avoir
il doit voir là la réponse et puis les
parents doivent être obligatoirement
accueilli par les directeurs d'école des
chefs d'établissement pluie deuxième
aspect très vite c'est les accompagnants
eux mêmes les accompagnants cela métier
qui est en train d'émerger d'apparaître
et là encore beaucoup une meilleure
formation
un meilleur accompagnement une meilleur
accueil par les chefs d'établissements
les directs de dire aussi c'est que
normalement à l'heure où je vous parle
normalement tous les enfants
vont avoir leur accompagnement leurs
accompagnants pardon sauf s'il y avait
une défection et c est en tout cas des
choses ont été suffisamment anticipé
dans les yvelines pour que cette coop
d'accompagnement soit effectif on a
compris une priorité pour l'éducation
nationale merci antoine destrés
directeur académique et des services de
l'éducation nationale des huiles merci
d'avoir été en plateau pour cette
première de la saison du 7-8 journal on
parlait justement nouveautés nouveauté
également dans les lycées d'île de
france cette année des établissements
qui s'ouvre davantage au numérique le
conseil régional qui a la compétence des
lycées a présenté ses investissements en
la matière pour la rentrée est les
détails de nos confrères de via grand
paris dans les lycées franciliens
ce n'est pas une page qui se tourne mais
un document pdf qui s'ouvre pour cette
rentrée les élèves seront équipés de
tablettes ou d'ordinateur 50 % des
établissements ont opté pour le tout
numérique
le matériel sera distribué gratuitement
aux élèves et aux enseignants pour trois
ans
montant de l'investissement 150 millions
d'euros soit 340 euros par élève
certains lycées resteront au sens pur
sans papiers souvent des lycées dans
lesquels les enfants ont déjà accès à
toute l'offre numérique à la maison les
lycées les plus privilégiés ont plutôt
choisi le papier en revanche il y à un
grand nombre de lycées qui ont choisi de
s'engager dans le tout numérique
notamment les lycées dans lesquels les
enseignants sont plus jeunes les équipes
pédagogiques plus jeune et je crois que
ça correspond aux standards mondiale
désormais les manuels seront disponible
en pdf
les lycéens pourront aussi accéder à
d'autres supports pédagogiques
nous allons mettre à la disposition des
lycéens l'application qui ose qui est
une application gratuite faite par la
région pour apprendre les langues
étrangères qui est un véritable
laboratoire de langues entièrement faits
avec des vidéos entièrement ludique et
qui remplace le laboratoire de langues
sur votre tablette
cette entreprise francilienne qui va
fournir aux lycéens les tablettes elles
sont dédiées à l'environnement scolaire
on va se retrouver
dans une interface dédiée avec un
environnement à la fois scolaire mais
qui reprend aussi des services de la
région
et puis un accès à l'ensemble des
ressources donc des manuels numériques
qui vont permettre aux enfants
de consulter tous les contenus deux cent
soixante mille élèves et 20 mille
enseignants profiteront de cette
révolution numérique c'est l'une des
actualités de la rentrée l'assemblée
nationale planche à partir d'aujourd'hui
sur le projet de loi orientation à des
mobilités l'un des points abordés
données aux départements la possibilité
au cas par cas de repasser à la vitesse
de 90 km heure sur les axes secondaires
à double sens un séparateur central m et
certaines collectivités dont celle des
yvelines affirme que le gouvernement
leur complique la tâche dans un
communiqué paru cet été le président du
conseil départemental pierre bédier
dénonce la duplicité du gouvernement
elle et lui met en cause les conditions
posées par une grille d'analysé
seuls les tronçons de plus de 10 km sort
eux seront concernés seraient concernés
par exemple avec un total dans les
yvelines 2 500 km de voies qui
repasserait à 90 km/heure sur 1600 km au
total
on continue de parler transport avec ce
projet qui pourrait à l'avenir améliorer
votre qualité de vie pourquoi pas donner
une réponse efficace aussi au problème
des bouchons en ile de france un
collectif travaille sur le rer b réseau
express régional vélo autrement dit à
pouvoir circuler plus facilement à des
lots dans la région à travers un réseau
cyclable cohérent et unifié et ce
collectif ces vélos ile-de-france dont
vous êtes le porte parole stan van
oosten bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous alors présenté nous déjà ce
collectif il regroupe je crois une
centaine d'associations francilienne
nous as a commencé avec 21 associations
aujourd'hui nous sommes 28 associations
4000 adhérents qui ont décidé de se
connecter pour parler d'une seule voix
vélo qui n'exprime qu'un ce désir à
savoir que l'ensemble des franciliennes
et des franciliens devraient pouvoir se
déplacer tranquillement une sécurité un
vélo et pour y arriver nous voulons être
un interlocuteur principal pour
l'ensemble des collectivités au sein de
la région ile de france pour leur
apporter notre expertise et notre
coordination
comment émerger justement cette idée de
créer de proposer ce rer vélo nous avons
partagé un constat entre associations en
ile de france il est très compliqué de
se déplacer à vélo d'une vie
à une autre alors qu'en voiture vous
avez des lignes vous avez des routes
départementales en rer vous avez des
lignes aussi vous avez des voies ferrées
alors qu'en vélo vous avez des petits
bouts par ci par là des bouts de pistes
et nous voulons coller les morceaux
ensemble pour en fait des véritables
lignes et même un réseau qu'on appellera
donc le rer vélo le rer b
afin de permettre à tous les franciliens
de se déplacer à plus facilement
on conçoit une idée peut-être voir une
ébauche de cartes je précise qui est
qu'une ébauche voilà les discussions
sont ouvertes les avis aussi des
franciliens sont les bienvenus les
objectifs au final du rer b c et voilà
c'est de proposer effectivement ce ce
réseau cohérent et unifié de pouvoir
circuler de ville en ville en
ile-de-france tout à fait c'est vraiment
pour connecter mais c'est surtout pour
créer une solution continue parce
qu'aujourd'hui 60% des français
aimeraient faire du vélo mais ils
n'osent pas soit parce qu'ils ont peur
parce que les il n'y a pas de
suffisamment d'infrastructures et
protégé ou parce que ça manque il n'y a
pas de continuité sur réseau va
véritablement mettre un réseau de
transport de qualité à deux kilomètres
de chaque francilien et sa valeur donc
leur leur permettre de ne pas s'empêtrer
dans les embouteillages mais de prendre
le vélo est ce que c'est une réflexion
sur l'île de france dans cette petite
couronne c'est une réflexion plus
globale est ce que les yvelines par
exemple sont sont concernés par votre
réflexion
les yvelines sont concernés en fait ça
concerne l'intégralité de la région ile
de france il vit aussi il y a quatre
lignes que nous prévoyons pour l'instant
donc j'invite aussi les spectateurs et
spectatrices à nous contacter via
l'adresse mail que nous avons s'affiche
actuellement à l'écran il y aura quatre
lignes une ligne qui va qui va commencer
de conflans défense paris ensuite poissy
défense paris une autre saint nom la
bretèche
rocancourt paris et puis une quatrième
ligne qui va démarrer de saint cyr vie à
versailles et ensuite paris et alors
vous avez a priori déjà ce que vous
disiez entamé vous souhaité entamer des
discussions avec les élus français a
notamment la la région ile de france je
vous propose d'écouter à ce propos
valérie pécresse qui réagit à ce projet
de rer b c'est mickaël millero qui
l'interrogeaient je vais recevoir les
associations
qui propose effectivement ces tracés de
rer à vélo est effectivement moi j'y
suis très très je suis très intéressé
parce que le plan vélo de la région
c'est quoi c'est un plan qui doit aider
au franchissement de ville et au
franchissement de département donc c'est
quelque chose qui doit essayer de faire
des liaisons qu'ils soient des maisons
des grandes transversale donc on va
travailler effectivement avec eux mais
d'ores et déjà dans les yvelines on a un
certain nombre de deux passerelles de
pont qu'on veut faire pour passer au
dessus des fleuves qui permettront
d'avoir des franchissements et qui
permettront en vélo de se développer
c'est bien qu'à vous allez rencontrer
prochainement valérie pécresse
à ce sujet on aimerait beaucoup on est
très contents d'entendre ça on l'a déjà
rencontré à pauvres pour prendre un
contact mais le fait de l'entendre
parler positivement de ce projet est
gravé c'est une excellente nouvelle
elle parle de franchissement de des
départements c'est exactement sur le
coeur de ce projet c'est d'éviter que
les politiques restent dans leur coin à
se disent tiens nous on s'occupe de ce
secteur et pas des autres secteurs
il essaie vraiment de se dire qu'on a
une région on va prendre une hauteur de
vue en tout le monde a des problèmes de
mobilité créant un réseau qui va
connecter nord au sud est ouest c'est un
peu comme quand vous installer un
ascenseur dans un immeuble ça ne se
discute pas avec les voisins du deuxième
il 4éme étage se discute avec tout le
monde et de vous invitons à madame
pécresse a invité l'ensemble des
collectivités autour de la table pour
entamer ces discussions ensemble mais
j'imagine que c'est le principal frein
aujourd'hui à ce projet c'est de mettre
tous les acteurs autour d'une table de
pouvoir relier ces réseaux existants et
forcément ça coûte aussi de l'argent de
faire ces aménagements effectivement
sens en argent ne peut rien faire
il ya des ruptures urbaine physique il
ya des fleuves dont elle a tant de
madame pécresse a parlé mais
effectivement il ya le manque ou
l'absence on va dire de mal le mans
plutôt de de volonté politique
collective la volonté politique existe
il ya paris ya le 93 aussi qui ont lancé
un gros plan vélo avec un budget pour
rendre l'ensemble des routes
départementales cyclables mais on n'a
pas encore eu une discussion avec
véritablement l'ensemble des acteurs
autour de la table pour créer ce projet
de façon cohérente et globale et
poursuivre les prochaines étapes on peut
aller notamment sur votre twitter
collectif vélos ile de france donnait
aussi son avis au projet je le rappelle
avec cette adresse qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci steinmann forem
d'être passé sur ce plateau et je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
du collectif vélos ile de france
merci beaucoup de vélo il en a été
question cet été avec l'un à des
événements majeurs dans les yvelines
c'était la dernière étape du tour de
france alors là vous voyez l'arrivée du
paris brest paris à vélo je vous parle
mois du tour de france la dernière étape
qui passait par rambouillet fin juillet
c'était le 28 juillet exactement des
milliers de supporters de toute la
france et même du monde était présent
pour voir passer la caravane et ses
supporters michael et demi d'euros
revient sur cet événement et vitrines
vélo maillot rambouillet et aux couleurs
du tour de france ce dimanche 28 juillet
la grande boucle fait escale dans la
cité royale à l'occasion du départ de la
dernière étape vers paris une première
depuis juillet 2012
ce que du bonheur c'est l'aboutissement
de huit mois de travail
mais l'équipe high tone naturellement et
puis une centaine une bonne centaine de
bénévoles mais effectivement c'est du
bonheur parce que on va enfin vivre
cette journée est renvoyée tant attendu
pour les rambos littamé pour le
territoire et pour beaucoup de visiteurs
naturellement le rendez vous a attiré
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
spectateurs sur cette journée
l'occasion pour ces aficionados du vélo
d'approcher les coureurs qui les ont
fait vibrer cette année on habite en
région centre
on a pas d'étapes côté jean d'accord
donc on est obligé de faire deux heures
de route pour venir les voir
j'espère rencontrer beaucoup de coureurs
que j'aime bien que je voudrais pas voir
devant moi parce que à la télé c'est
bien d'y voir des vents de 100 corps
mieux celui que tout le monde veut voir
c'est lui et gagnent pernal à 22 ans le
coureur colombien est presque assuré de
remporter le tour de france avant le
départ à rambouillet il doit juste
terminer l'étape
un résultat qui enthousiasme les
milliers de supporters colombien présent
dans les yvelines
[Applaudissements]
je suis très très heureux c'est l'un des
plus grand jour de ma vie c'est une joie
très grande c'est la première fois qu'un
sportif colombien remporte le tour de
france c'est quelque chose de très
important et nous sommes fiers de
représenter notre drapeau et notre pays
une fois les signatures et laissez-les
fit terminer direction la ligne de
départ pour les spectateurs pour voir le
départ de la caravane et de ses 160
véhicules décorés aux couleurs des
marques
les coureurs s'élancent ensuite à 18h10
depuis le parc du château de rambouillet
et en direction de paris
les yvelinois reverront le tour de
france l'année prochaine une convention
a été signée par le département pour
accueillir la dernière étape de la
grande boucle jusqu'en 2023
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal on se
retrouve dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition d'information locale belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]